well day two what have we learned about
the awesome statement let's start with
the big picture this is real household
disposable income it's basically kind of
how well off we're feeling over the
course of the last few years you can see
kind of the level going up and up and up
then you have the financial crisis
that's where that line ends now had it
continued in line with where it was
going that's where it would have been
but as we all know that's not what
happened it flatlined we had that kind
of lost decade for growth and I'm afraid
the story now is basically another lost
decade look at that line that's the
forecast it's going to be flatlining and
the upshot of it is have a look at the
gap between the two of them we're going
to be one-third worse off than we would
have been had that line carried on
Rising as it was before the financial
crisis that's quite depressing it's
worth offsetting that the government is
trying to do things to help out here and
when it comes to energy bills look the
amount of support in the UK that's the
Red Bar there and the higher these are
the more support there is just money
being kind of dispersed there it's
greater in the UK especially after this
Autumn statement uh intervention than in
any other country or major country in in
the EU worth saying those are Cash
numbers there's a percent of GDP is
slightly low and it's still it's still
really high but offset against that is
the fact that taxes are rising and more
people are being dragged into higher
rates of tax and one way of looking at
that is by looking at kind of who is
facing higher levels of tax so anything
below the line is basically paying more
tax than anything above the line is kind
of getting a giveaway by your income
levels so you're looking at earnings
there the further you are over there the
more you're earning to give you an
example here someone at 62 000 pounds
they will take a 1 600 pound hit now the
line is flat all the way up into 124
000 pounds so if you're 124 000 pounds
that's also 1 600 pounds but here's the
thing you probably noticed this already
look at those boxes for someone on 62
000 pounds 1 600 pounds is 2.6 of their
earnings compared with 1.3 of the
earnings of someone who is earning much
more you see the point it's the middle
which is being really squeezed here and
another way of looking at that is it
looking who what share of adults are
paying the higher rate of tax it used to
be quite a small proportion that we're
paying that 40p rate back in the early
90s under four percent but look at how
that line has gone up more and more
people being dragged into that higher
rate so that now at the end of the
forecast Horizon you're talking about
nearly 15 so more people paying those
higher levels of tax it really was a tax
raising Autumn statements and that is
the day two verdict so far